baba tag means the opponent has the usa
so well falls in the suit what mostly goes on to
something
yes
that happens sometimes i mean
the c5 right but
then c4
so you can now play jump five
or are you so does it bring something
good  if i don't do that then
you ask yourself what it was all good for
that's what it's called again he has to
destroy the leg position
has also had also allowed and of
course two are still hanging
hmm well
springer c3 or just cover him
the state is still quite active
i mean  Structurally it looks stupid
but
he's just quite active
well that was catching up on
development so well I don't really like it
she somehow looks quite good here
but the parts are all good
making the runner cologne nor the g6 he also
has it  an active
diagonal I somehow didn't get anything out of it
yes I actually thought spinners 4 each
would be convincing
or not
so the runner now  t it
can't be easy and that's what I think it
does because now we have to get them
or the four but okay I can
also hit
if he puts the runners down so
nicely and I take him out that's
how it is  is now what about
a direct attempt
41 runners the three
see that you can take the tempi all with you
springer b4 he can do but then
i would easily have three as i said
okay move away and then it runs
like this it looks a bit stupid
with the farm
but he if he locked the runner here a
bit but good then takes
away the field of five and also if
the runner comes by law then
he also points to granite
soy c50 probably wants to play
i would like to prevent it but
i don't see it really  how well
is easy three first of
all we have at least two runs
yes that was to be expected
gymnastics club makes sense on the toe
pawns
that I reckon jet  currently also
with c4 otherwise i played three at the time
and then there is the case so
it does it several times but nothing
against good news now it
often says here 15 53 times and says in the
bondage
i can't prefer it i know
now  not at all what he's playing so honestly
what's he playing now springer ag 7 must
also reckon with the fact that I'll take a 7 times
so that's obviously not that interesting right away
maybe the candy
four
springer you five could be the idea
but of course it depends  still take the
kids around
well
a7 has nuclear power
probably through
thun c3 also doesn’t look bad from
the c 30 c 1 go on it again
there can’t be ten jumpers you
five think I know he hangs five I
mean maybe you can  still
play but
not as if it works that's
how it is now, I think it's quite
harmonious,
maybe I have to play f3 too,
so first of all,
maybe
optically  it
's nice we'll do the train im not quite
sure but
so the four fat ones would like to
clear the tent d1 maybe i can
import it sometime and then
your down here
so i'm thinking x it
can be that that's totally artificial
nonsense  but
that's not easy
then open the position
so i swing more towards the
marriage line
all the more often c4 now the next
idea he likes it
27 now
a main problem is, as usual, the time mathys
so
26 comes the g7 matt
production is good  but I don't have anything
left on the bell
yes I'm lame duck
oh yes that was actually quite good but
opening the position was for switzerland on
plain suicide of course but
then of course it kind of looks as
if you're like that here but she's not
I don't see anything  directly mine was of
course not bad
yes good but with six seconds